so living amongst the highest mountains
in the philippines
and calling themselves the sky people
the ifugao
are masters of terracing and they use
water
and soil and rocks as construction
techniques and tools and the terraces
that they form are unique micro
watersheds that
serve as rain water filtration systems
for the waters
that are passing through this mountain
landscape and they're a combination of
shallow
water very high nutrient levels high
primary productivity and they are
incredibly ideal conditions
for growing organisms that form the base
of our food webs
what that means is that many species
actually rely
on these rice terraces in these
incredible mountainous landscapes for
food
for water and for shelter and especially
birds that are actually flying through
and passing on their migrations through
this landscape
and that makes them really incredibly
important for global
biodiversity so these constructed rice
terraces are actually one of our
most important ecosystem and they act as
these
massive absorption and water
purification
systems as well as nutrient and
biodiversity storehouses with
a scale and a steepness that's really
synonymous with
our skyscrapers in our cities their
biological
performance has the potential to really
inform how do we
integrate landscapes into our vertical
cities the vertical landscapes of our
cities and it really hints at how our
urban
vertical environments could become also
havens for
aquatic terrestrial and airborne
biodiversity
as well as urban agriculture with
incredible irrigation systems
you